skincare mistake to stop doing number  two transferring products into a  different container and this is  especially bad for sunscreen it can be  okay but firstly the container has to be  very clean the product's preservative  system might not be able to cope with  dust or bits of packaging or old product  or mold spores inside your new container  and you won't necessarily be able to see  these things secondly some container  materials might not be compatible with  particular ingredients glass is usually  okay but plastics can react common  ingredients that can be problematic are  preservatives active ingredients  solvents and sunscreen filters if a  sunscreen ingredient soaks into the  plastic from your sunscreen then your  sunscreen won't work as well